this capsule we will introduce the
history concept g fat then holds
we saw that thanks to the image gradient
it was possible to do the detection
of contagion now we will see that the
image bleachers can also be
useful for extracting
useful features of an image for
solve different vision problems
by computer including
object recognition so we saw that
gradient orientation actually does not
does not want varied according to
the intensity that is to say that in the
representation in the form of orientation
gradient for a given image to the
gradients make it possible to separate
training on the intensity of
variations a given place
so this more specified by the standard of
guardian and direction of variations
in an image is rather given
by the gradients orientation question
so the idea here is to try
to use this property the dgrad
imagery
get features that are
more variants with respect to
the intensity of an ihm of the peaks in a
image and variations between forgotten
just variations
of elimination in an image
the characteristic we will see is this
which is called the gradient histogram
in english histogram of credit and sue
we often want time of the acronym org
which breaks down into four stages
different
the first step is simply to do
a calculation of gradients in an image
so the fields ie the
gradients to each of the pixels in a
picture
so that's something we know
do we have seen so far in
either we will partition or divide
the image into several segments that we are going to
pleaded in English gasoline so
imagine we have a big picture
but when also in simple format
there divided into different segments where
finally each of the subregions
here you fits a different segment
and we could also choose to
to take bleeding
overlapping each other but the coc
simpler if just take some
segments that finally partition
dividing different segments all
an image of me too is some
something that is simple to do and then
of sauce we are going to make is a
histogram of the orientations
observe in each of the segments for
each of the segments we will watch
what are the orientations of
bleachers that is inside the
segment is offered a histogram of its
directions and then finally for
get a feature vector
then simply conques to hold the
box values ​​of all
histograms in all segments
so the idea here is get a vector
x that we could perhaps give in
input a learning algorithm like
a proud glacis round percepts or
logistic regression we will reason is
the vector x it will be obtained in
conquest and ultimately has the value of
boxes of every moment g in all
the segments
how does a histogram calculate for a
segment finally give an example here where
we have one of the boxes so a little calm
one of the segments in an image so
imagine like a tiger in still picture
also one of the boxes you have a place
given in an image then to calculate
the histogram of orientations
we will take we will partition all
the possible directions so zero
up to 360 degrees in a certain
number of cases so we could decide
to have four possible boxes costil that
here we have the box at 0 a center is at
zero degree Corsican sorting 90 ° lake to
180 ° Cance 270 ° to practice on
often uses more boxes per
example nothing to see 8 to 0 45 and
institutes and the value of each of
boxes in our story g it's going
actually match the count of the number
gradient that falls into each of
cards
so in fact every guardian in my
segment will finally vote
for orientation and orientation there
must vote is the most
close to its orientation
so we have an example here of a segment in
n 9
xl so nine gradient when if this
gradient if only radian6 and this guardian
also voted for zero since its more
close the author the gas with a
orientation of zero degree orientation
the closest among 0 90 180 and 270 not
we have three votes for this
orientation there is then five who have
an orientation closer to 180
degrees we feel that here and finally
we only have one vote for an orientation
from 278
ok so that's a first approach
to extract a gradient histogram
in a segment
now we might want to
take into account the magnitude so the
standard of gradients for example one
actually remark that it may be a
strange little that the gradient here here here
a vote as high as the gradients
which correspond to more variations
high in the picture
so here actually already because we have a
gradient that is weak maybe that
our estimate of the gradient or
the orientation of the caretaker
maybe not so good
variations could easily change
in fact
the orientation at that place so
maybe we'll be more robust by
relation to that and for faso must hold
account of the standard this gradient because
it's a first approach it's just
to add an additional box for
gradients who would just have a man
which is smaller advice give so
we might have a fifth box
so the plain christmas but there it is
simply a box that corresponds in
made to the vote gradients whose
standard is too small and smaller than a
certain threshold
the lightning is specified a given threshold or
another approach it would actually be
take each of the gradients and the
to vote but with some weight
and so the importance of their vote the
weight of their life is going to be
proportional to the gradient standard
question so I'm going to take my
guardian quim well worth squared I
sum it up as the norm
Christian no sorry that's death
opportunity kaori so I take the root
square of savanna the norm is so the
vote of an ingredient at the position and j
it's going to be proportional to the standard of
his guardian then in fact we're going
normalize to be anyway and
varying in relation to the elimination so
we will finally normalize by the sum
standards of all gradients
teaching so in what if
since we have enormous standards here
we will still be a variant by
relation to elimination
and if we make that approach there in
the example here because standards are
of his three guardians then are
supposedly three times higher than the
standards of these three cardiologists that these
standards if they are almost zero then
for zero degrees that is the orientation of
his guards then 67% of the votes
because 32% of the votes go rather
go to 180 so if it's gradient the water
here then these two blocks are rather 1 to
0 and 1 or 1 because of this guardian
watch it are almost 7
so the first approach which is to
have a specific additional box
for guards who are too small
it can help to better represent
the presence of regions that are
basically a woman so who have
credit standards come in at the little bit
of variation so if one in a
given application is still a
information we want to extract we want
maybe have this box there to see a
vote which is rather standardized by
ratio by dividing to enter the
standard of the gradients of each of the
keepers in this segment by ten years by
sum of guardian numbers
it will give a representation that
still remains quite invariant by
relation to elimination what is a
little less true here because we're going
distinguish between this ingredients
which we call small in absolute value and
what high standards have presented
also to combine both the two
sites and sets
so there are different variations so
to have a box then anyway
standard of gradients 12:30 a space there
variations that can be considered on
the fictional gradient histograms
explore in in literatures in
vision applications by
computer
here is an example we illustrate
finally the representation extracted
by calculating gas histograms
everywhere in an image so here we have
an image is here we have an illustration
histograms so the way that was
illustrated in fact is that for example
here so that will fit roughly
a website
this area also actually because if
so I'm going to take off a little bit better
my box so here for the box here
about
we observe, among other things, that we are afraid of
gradients that go in that direction
also or maybe this direction if
since we have an outline like what is
con here is clearly in the ground and so
for in the illustration here we go
actually show the the perpendicular of
these gradient has so for example the
social gradient something like us
have degree there is demonstrated here as
that then for 180 degrees he would
demonstrated as this one so it allows
to see a little more visually than
actually in this part of
the image and it was detected by the itanium
of gas that we have variations that are
more vertical and horizontal and have for
all the boxes here we have this
illustration of the histograms of
gradient and we see that all the same but
precisely in this part if the image
we have the information that there are mostly
vertical variations and less
horizontal variations then to others
places in the image that we gave
some combinations of with
different weights of variation of sound
talent and vertical or in fact paul
just vertical horizontal but
also diagonal in situ and so if
it corresponds to an example of extraction
characteristics that correspond to
gradient histogram and when one
could do is take all these
values ​​there for each of the boxes
take value from each by
each of the segments take to each
boxes of the histograms and put that
in a vector where we managed the
first box of the first segment of
the histogram of the first segment the
second frame of the first segment and
so on for all the boxes of
all the histograms so in every
hits of the segments one could take
if he gave it that does not lead to algorithms
learning to solve a
given problem
and that's what we'll describe a little more
by the next caps them